here comes bill hader welcome sir we
were just talking about a you know that
confidence that HBO clearly has in Barry
at this point Oh does that feel just
because like they put it on after Game
of Thrones it's the first thing you see
when you turn on HBO or whatever like
it's this thing let HBO wants people to
see it
right yeah does that feel good or does
it not even yeah I didn't really think
about it until you just said that you
should complain about a shooting no I
can't explain yeah you can't get mad
about uh yeah we and we didn't really
put that together until right before it
happened they were like oh you know it
was our first two shows that aired and
they go so now a week three you know you
have a new lead in it's Game of Thrones
and then veep and we were like I hadn't
I hadn't seen it so I recorded it and I
watched the pilot yesterday it's [ __ ]
boy I haven't seen it was really great
Thank You Man
yeah I loved it much so you didn't you
didn't get to this place where you're
like starts at 10:20 no no no no yeah
it's gonna be well no our things are
always like yeah they just keep like
getting pushed because those episodes
are so long and then we went and saw the
battle went it felt like they had a
giant screening of it at Mann's Chinese
in LA and it was just it was really cool
like all these people came and and it
was the day it aired and we had an
episode called Rani Lily where I there's
like this like basically but hit goes
wrong and there's this little girl that
attacks Barry and and then we're
watching Game of Thrones this little
girl jumps on me you guys don't see that
first no no no no and it's just funny
that so many people like would stop me
like that's so cool that you did like
like a whole episodes just one big fight
because you knew batter one two fellas
gonna be I'm like no no clue I love the
that people think that like well yeah of
course they would let the guys who make
Barry see Game of Thrones no crossover
let's see this strips yeah
come out yeah I was reading that I
didn't eat and I didn't know your dad
did stand up yeah and was he good I I
guess not cuz he stopped doing it but
now he's really funny but I think I
think you stopped knowing he was pretty
funny but I think he stopped because
they had us when we're really they're
really young my parents and my my dad
but I think by that time they had like
three kids my mom was like no she was
like you gotta work cuz we've got three
kids but it'd be like what's the place
in Houston showcase or economy I know
she's there's a place in Houston there
that stop no it's it like we're bill hey
yeah I could picture the sign it's like
a big it's the spot that Bill Hicks
started it and I can't remember a club
but used to [ __ ] okay yeah baby way that
was like that was like the one spot that
he he went to like once I wasn't
something he was actually doing for a
while now yeah he was like maybe they
don't have it anymore
so does he live like did you start
living vicariously through you a little
bit when you started not in a nice way
no not really he was just like so like
wow this is great
wow this is insane you know like when
when I got a I remember he came to an
SNL once and I got to say live from New
York just happened to say live from New
York and he was like beaming afterwards
yeah you know I had him stand right by
the little tunnel thing you know and I
was like oh come on you know I'm gonna
cold open and when he saw that he was
like I just remember watching this with
you and you were a kid performing
apparently I hate it oh yeah I don't
like it no don't I get very like I don't
like performing from anybody I know it's
really stupid but I get really uptight
you know we like in the middle of a
thing like what are you looking at me
like that word as to know you can't
always admired stand-ups you could say
what's wrong with you yeah that's what
I'm I read sketch people is that you
can't do that it's harder yeah I guess I
calming if something's not going well
you can address it but it's sketchy
there's a [ __ ] that's hard man
it's terrible and and also when it's
live on the for the whole nation to see
and you're like in your head we all are
like well this is bombing Plus everybody
loves with SNL for some reason I feel
like more than any other show everybody
loves the next morning be like you know
sucks no you used to be good at right
it's all suck I always was that way and
I remember people going this sucks this
sucks you vote it sucks and then when
when me and Fred we're leaving it was
like then those same people wrote these
big things about me and Fred and
Sudeikis and what we did for the show
and of course on early and now the new
cast sucks because they're not you guys
yeah exactly and I was like and I tell
that to the new cast like when I go back
like just so you know we sucked to the
inside if you got to leave for them to
be like you know what they did that was
so great you know when you're in a
sketch and it's bah it's behind you know
it's bombing like you can kind of tell
thinking about the show you could tell
very fast like oh [ __ ] this is not gonna
be good there's nothing you can't break
now and I mean I mean yeah I was happy
in that that I didn't I feel like I
didn't break when something was bombing
I usually if I broke it was because
Mulaney had written something or or Fred
Armisen was doing something during the
sketch like he would do a different
voice suddenly I'm run one time in a
sketch it took place in the 40s and Fred
just came in with a New York Giants
jacket on and I started laughing and
then he took his jacket I do find it I'm
going give me the jacket what are you
doing just came in the New York Giants
jacket on just [ __ ] with me and but when
it was bombing I remember me and Will
Forte did a sketch called you'll never
gonna believe this a bomb it was called
fart face and where we were we were with
Josh Brolin and we were like these these
businessmen that were like hello John
hello Jerry
hello Karl you know nothing you know
real word in the street is you're a real
fart face you know like I'm not a fart
face and it was us being very like that
but talking about fart face you just say
fart face over his head but then it did
it escalates to Josh Brolin killing
himself and
and and we did it at dress and it bombed
and and then for some reason we walked
in and it was on the board and it was
right after update and more Michaels
just liked how committed we were because
it were playing it like super dramatic
but we're just saying fire face alone
and and I just remembered going oh my
god we're gonna have to do this on air
this is gonna bomb and I remember
sitting back there before we went out
with it was me and Will Forte and Josh
Brolin all dressed as old businessman
looking at each other and Josh Brolin
looked at the audience he goes well
fellas let's shut these [ __ ] up got
the big laughs no bomb you could hear
our footfalls like I could hear when you
across it was so quiet and it just
bombed horribly and I think
Entertainment Weekly or someone was like
it built like billet or a wolf worth
they were walking out to do one sketch
and then found a sketch in the trash
called fart face and said oh wait let's
do this one instead bombing stories are
so entertaining they're so yeah like I
get that sketch had killed I wouldn't
want to hear about it but the fact that
it bombed and you knew it was gonna bomb
again this just it's a you're going out
there to get the [ __ ] kicked out again
you're like it bombed once and now yeah
we know this doesn't work and no one's
even in the yell they're just gonna
quietly just listen to it oh it was
might have been the exact same show or
what were josh brolin was a guy who said
has anybody seen the fall foilage it was
like again it was like a it was like a
conference for me was the fall foilage
is here the buttery Browns the golden
yellows you know all this stuff and it
was just him talking about he's like no
one no one has seen the fall and it was
bombing kind of staring at each other
like the whole joke was that no one says
anything in the business meeting and
then we started laughing because it
bombed so hard I started smiling in Andy
Samberg because we knew Kenan
the line was has anybody ever gone up to
he leaves and they go is anybody ever
gone up to see fall foliage with him and
Kenan Thompson's line was yes he allowed
me to be raped
so we knew this line was terrible
Kanan was like it's not funny it's not
want to say this especially oh there's
been no lacerate he allowed me to be
raped is light and I just remember I
started laughing cuz we all were like
now Kenan has to say this awful line and
Kenan is looking like you [ __ ]
kidding me
I got a now saying but at least that
line saves it no there's nothing that
can ice an audience more than the word
right I mean it's not forward
deliverance reference about yeah yeah
yeah we were just like so that was the
only time we're like I feel it wasn't
the line it was just like oh this is so
we all felt so bad for Kenan that he's
like well gonna have to [ __ ] eat this
[ __ ] now to say this super unfunny I
would have been really happy to know
that my friend had a bomb we were just
like we all it was bored just like
sympathy like I'm so sorry you don't
have to say this terrible unfunny line
I'm somebody's the guys can stay in
character and like and still commit to
it it's it's got to be so tempting uh
does Lauren grill that into people don't
break the wall because nobody really
does it and it's got to be so tempting
just to try to go for the lamp and yeah
yeah he does I mean when I would do the
stuff on stuff and I would break a lot I
would always go and apologize I'm like
I'm sorry lastly and he goes well if
what you're saying wasn't really funny
and it seems it's genuine then I'm I'm
fine with it and you know or like
there's a one of californians where we
all broke because Fred did a completely
different voice on air than he did the
dress rehearsal so when he started
talking about me and Kristin like really
[Laughter]
that's fine but I think if yeah the
thing was like not doing well and it was
quiet and like not going well and then
you start just like giggling or whatever
cuz it's not doing well I guess just
Lauren get upset when things bomb or
does he understand that this is part of
the I think he's just by the time it's
air he's kind of like we got it on the
air well why what are we gonna do it's
done yeah let's move on yeah that makes
sense
have you ever had when you're pitching
like when you have a bro and whoever it
is when you have a guest house come in
and you've got to say okay here
a sketch that I was thinking that we
could put you in and you could do this
have you ever bombed in front of just
that guests like bombed in the pitch
where the celebrities looking at you
talk oh yeah that's why and I fully will
admit I dialed back like my in the pitch
room like when you're pitching stuff on
Monday I wouldn't say I would just be
like I got an idea where we work at a
coffee shop like I just would like super
cuz I hate that feeling that you're
talking about cuz I was I remember I had
one it was in front of the room but I
remember pitching to make Jagger host it
I was like oh what if what if we did a
thing where I was Keith Richards
and you and I are on a plane together
and I wonder private plane is just the
two of us and you say oh I haven't heard
your book yet I'm gonna listen to your
book on the plane in the book is like
Keith Richards yeah who slam me and Mick
Jagger and he's like oh and I'm like oh
yeah it means like no Mike oh and then
like so the whole time he's listening
I'm trying to like get out of the plane
in midair and I'm trying to crash the
plane just like anything and then I keep
looking back and I'm he's like we just
met you know and and I pitched it to him
and he just stared I mean he went
nothing about Keith that's a funny pitch
though that's really a pitch it to him
and him just staring at me like blank
faith like the minute I was like well
I'm Keith you could just tell he was
like no I get it and I mean this is Mick
Jagger and he's hating what I'm saying a
hundred percent I was just staring at me
like are you [ __ ] kidding me and I
was like and I got it too like the
minute I said it it was I think I'm sure
you like what you're doing where you're
like oh he's so not into this and
instead of backing down I'm gonna try to
show more yeah and he's just looking at
me like now dude because like ten
minutes ago you had these great
fantasies of being in this hilarious
sketch with make friends after and this
is gonna be awesome and the fact that he
didn't the minute I said Keith Richards
name it was just like dude I've been
getting pitched this [ __ ] since like no
how nice need to have creative control
over that ever you direct a lot of these
words you actual
no I direct just a couple of Oh a couple
yeah but we're me and Alec Berg or the
showrunners of Barry that's nice right
to have the control yeah yeah no it's
awesome yeah I know it's and they've
been amazing HBO I mean we'll have
scenes in the show that are like just
fully dramatic and really you know dark
and things and we'll be at the table
read and they'll be kind of looking at
them like all right they're gonna say no
you know
instead they love it they're just like
hey no that's what and it's always
what's right for the character and they
really understand story how do you think
it change because it's a pretty high
concept show it's it you know hit man
goes to acting school becomes an actor
but it's so also kind of a hit man how
do you pitch HBO do you just give him
the premise do you give him scripts like
how do you we pitched them the whole
show like I pitched him essentially the
pilot that you saw like B 4 B 4 B 4 B
and so that it was like that pilot had
already aired and I was explaining like
this is what happens in it and and then
and then said you know we think it would
it's kind of about this guy who's
essentially you know he's killed people
and he thinks this is the only thing
this is all he's good for and it's kind
of you know destroyed his soul and he
wants to learn to be a human being and
instead of taking therapy he's gonna
learn through this acting class with all
these dopey actors and we were like yeah
it's like if Travis Bickle or the guy
from Unforgiven found solace with the
people from waiting for Guffman and
learned how to be a human through those
people and and I and I just remember
saying the violence is gonna be very
real it's not comedy violence it's not a
glib take on violence and it's gonna be
real cinematic looking it's not gonna be
kind of a like what you'd assume like a
comedy not kids like yeah yeah like
bright they're anything and then they
were like cool they really into it the
opening scene in the pilot is just great
it's just you know I guess a hotel room
and it just pans and there's a guy with
a bullet in his head in the bed
immediately you're interested like
well obviously it's just shot this guy
be your casually leaving the room it's
what a great opening soon that was very
strategic that opening because I think
because it was me and Alec Berg people
it's gonna be funny and we wanted
initially to be like know that like lead
with that and then let the comedy come
in after that you know but this is this
guy's life you know and let the body be
in the foreground like you know it's
like I remember talking that I can't
camera guys saying the brandon trois the
deep heals like yeah I should feel like
he's that's not that body it's just like
you know like a bathrobe he took off and
threw on the bed that's how he relates
to it it's like nothing you know so no
so it was helpful yeah it was good yeah
but I immediately want to know why is
this guy in the room with this yeah yeah
of course yeah at what point in making
the series do you start thinking about
how do we where do we go after season 1
where do we go after season 2 how does
this concept move because you don't want
to put the the cart before the horse but
at the same time you don't want to blow
your load and then get a season 2 or
season 3 after this one and go like okay
what do we do now there's always these
kind of like tentpole moments that we
talked about in the writers room or
we'll talk about something like for
instance and season that people are
haven't seen the show about to spoil
something but in a in a season - there's
something while we were writing season 1
we were like oh what if this guy loach
has an ex you know an ex wife what if
you would want berry at some point to
kill the new boyfriend and I was like oh
that's good that doesn't work in season
1 but we should do that in season 2 and
we we did that you know gotcha so you
kind of keep it and know that you're
yeah you kind of have that in your
pocket and you kind of move that along
that along you have these little tempo
moments of like where it to go and you
write towards those but then those
Temple moments kind of they change they
morph or you get there and you're like
this isn't that important and but but to
be honest I mean we we don't let me show
we're gonna shy wina in October we're
all gonna sit down and look at each
other and go alright so you guys think
that happens next
how do you henry winkler's that's what
someone's idea or did I be obvious it
was someone's idea but did you writing
this you're like [ __ ] Henry Winkler's
perfect yeah I mean I will know we wrote
it actually really arch it was kind of
like this big kind of like theatrical
like two dimensional acting coach
character and we didn't write a very
good character and then when Henry came
in and read it he auditioned and when he
read it he was so good and like I mean
he was Mamiya were like Oh failed actor
he made the character kind of like this
failed actor and he just was more of a I
know you just had more of a sympathy for
him and he's also a bit more of a prick
than you used to see in him clearly a
little cocky err a little bit it's funny
he's really great I mean because he's
such a nice man he's the nicest human
being on the planet yeah yeah but he's
so good at not like that's how you know
he's authentic about being the nicest
human being on the planet is that he's
not precious about making sure that when
you see me on this show I want everybody
to also know I'm nice like he doesn't
care he'll play he's an inheritor yeah
yeah everybody on our cast is really
nice and they all have to play varying
degrees of [ __ ] they're all great
there was something happened in the pile
let's say what it is if you haven't seen
the pilot but the angle the pilot went
in I thought I knew exactly how it was
gonna go and then something happened to
her oh [ __ ]
well that did not end the way I thought
it was gonna so it's just it's great now
I'm annoyed I haven't seen more of them
what's it like having to write after
going through SNL and that sort of
content factory where it's you know this
week matters for this week only now
everything gets thrown out now let's go
to next week and it's just like
move-move-move
new stuff new stuff new stuff to live in
this space where you're writing for
these same characters now over what's
going to be three years and kind of
telling what really is one long story
yeah that's how we view it is yeah one
long story and kind of that's the
hardest thing is like oh we're repeating
ourselves we're doing the same beat here
because if you I always say that in the
writers room like think of this is like
one giant book called you know berry and
it's you know this each season is a part
and it's like how are we gonna you know
how's it changed how does it morph and
that's a nice thing that HBO is that
they do like you doing that you know
we're a lot of shows it's like no no no
keep it works we have the formula why
are you why you messing with it I like
the I mean it's scary the but messing
with a is great and I tend to I was
never very good at writing sketches and
I was never very good at writing like
just jokes I was not good at like the
kind of stuff Seth Meyers and John
Mulaney and those guys could do or I was
always like I don't know how you do that
but I do think this kind of writing is
the thing I'm I was more prone to you
know ending a sketch is harder than
writing the jokes I think finding it in
like we're like tada like so just not
end it we were just yeah there are these
yeah there are these sketches and when
you're watching us and out where it's
just either applause starts or the
camera kind of pans out and you're like
oh I guess that's that's the end of the
music just starts and you're like oh
well that was that or like in fart face
we just went oh no he killed himself
out of that yeah did you ever did you
have any characters that you thought
we're gonna bomb then ended up being
pretty successful um I mean the stuff on
stuff we tried that as a sketch couple
of times and it didn't work that's what
I was thinking it's like Stefan is that
type of thing where if it doesn't click
it's either it's gonna go one of two
ways right yeah but it didn't work as a
sketch we did it as a sketch and it
didn't work and it was like not working
and then Doug Abel's who was running
update at the time was like hey do you
want to bring that party that weird
party guy guy on update like we we got
nothing on update it but I think that
characters funny if you want to come do
it this week and John I just you know I
mean it really all the writings John
Mulaney and and me just I I would
organize stuff sometimes but and pitch
things mostly when Stefan did like a
weird sound or something I'm like oh I
could do this weird this weird for the
odd sound weird sounds I can do that but
mostly it's just John or and and me like
editing you know but
but yeah I mean that was one where
suddenly that clicked and you don't know
why and you're just like well that's
right slayed by audience like that one
and then that I did it and then we had a
show and then Lauren was like can you do
that again
and he wanted another one so we did it
again just two shows later and then when
I came out I got this giant recognition
applause and it was like and I had never
gotten I mean I had original characters
on but nothing like that no that was
nothing that worked as well or pops off
like then you don't know why it was like
all right they're kind of out of the
habit making movies for like there was a
period of time where SNL would make a
movie for every popular character that
would they asked if we would want it
yeah hoovy about Stefan and that John
and I were late it didn't work as a
sketch it was like what you think you
want that and then you'll see it like on
a billboard and be like I don't want
that and there's a lot of discipline
that now does be based on your carrot
yeah you're just like I don't think you
want that you think you want that and
then you don't and then the other thing
I was saying was I was like also if we
really did a Stefan movie it's like sad
it's like not funny
right it's like a bummer like he's
homeless if we did it it would just be
this super sad right it's just it's
almost all a farce it's all fake it's
like know why he's there he doesn't know
where he is half the time half the [ __ ]
he sees alive was it you're at the earth
Alan Alda audition tape that went around
is that the one people were watching you
were doing all that in the audition or
no when was that for something else he's
auditioning for Back to the Future that
one that might a bit yeah really funny
yeah and you're gonna and you've got it
coming out in September right yeah it
yeah I'm in the sequel to it I mean
that's incredible yeah obviously I got
the first one i'm richie the Richie
Tozier serious so I'm like the big the
glasses and everything trashmouth were
you a fan of the book I had read the
book in high school yeah
and then and then you were like they
were like oh you're gonna read the book
again before making the movie and I was
like no I mean have it's like 1,200
pages it's a long book we started like
next month
yeah and I got [ __ ] to do I'll read the
script before the I read the script
you know I'll watch the other movie yeah
I watched and I actually I'm being it
sounds like I'm just being lazy and I
guess I but it was more like well I just
I'm gonna watch what Finn did in the
first movie the kid who played Ritchie
and just try to play off that so it
feels like a continuation of what the
movie well that's the best thing it's
like it is lazy but it's like no no I'll
make it an artistic choice that's the
book I'm gonna say this in interviews
like the funny one he's like the guy the
toys yeah yeah he's like yeah so he's
it's kind of a great thing because my
character is the one that's like what
that's stupid
yeah yeah yeah I love like my my pick oh
we got to go fine
Pennywise I'm like let's not yes tom is
it difficult to play like an adult
because there's almost no horror movies
like the adults are the ones that are
being chased by the villain right yeah
their kids or it's teenagers yeah this
one well this one is also all the
characters have such they have like
their you know that was so great about
it it's the thing that you're the most
afraid yeah you know and so it's it it's
about kind of just getting older yeah
and trying to get rid of your demons and
how you keep repeating the same mistakes
and in life and also it was actually
it's actually a very emotional movie to
be honest like I remember shooting it
going like this is like really it mean
it has all the creatures stuff and and
and all and all that which is a lot of
fun but I was surprised that how I was
like patos wasn't it
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]